Mirage is an Autobot spy who can
transform into a Sleek silver blue
Porsche and project Holograms he's
mainly tied to ex-military electronics
expert Noah as a fun and slightly
rebellious Force within the autobot
ranks having Mirage voiced by Pete
Davidson might give the impression that
the character will simply be comic
relief the name's Mirage
however there are plenty of ways that
the autobot could be much more than a
simple jokester mirage's transformation
abilities seem to be much more extensive
than his fellow Autobots which could
make for an incredible visual showcase a
sequence of Mirage transforming around
nowhere while in the middle of a Chase
is visually jaw-dropping and the idea of
the character being able to project
Holograms could be utilized for Unique
action sequences with Mirage tied to the
main character of the film he could also
be part of some big character moments
that show the robot's heart and yes
there will definitely be plenty of
one-liners from Davidson that will make
Mirage one of the funniest Transformers
brought to the big screen